this is dr. Lawrence Brown I'm back here
again at the invitation of my friend
Eddie reso Vic we're going to be talking
with you about the middle path don't go
anywhere this is really going to be a
nice show please be with you welcome to
the dto i'm eddie your host another week
another exciting episode another
exciting guest is about to come out in a
minute we're going to be talking about
the middle path people become religious
quote on quote and now they might end up
doing some very extreme things and then
the whole religion gives blame and then
some people experience the truth they
realize there is a purpose in life they
start to live it they enjoy it but then
they slack off they go to another to
exclaim they become extremely neglectful
of their responsibilities so how do we
as those who have come to know what the
purpose of life is we're living a way of
life that's pleasing to the crater how
do we stay on the middle path but we got
our brother coming out who's got a ton
of experience a ton of years in Islam my
next guest dr. Lewis brown with him here
on the D show when we come back don't go
anywhere this is
this is the thing you know this is the
this is the and my next guest started
off as an atheist that's right tried
very hard to be a Christian and now he's
on the Dean show he's figured out the
purpose of life and how we gonna stay on
the moderate pav when it get his
experiences in life in the Dean where my
next guest dr. Lawrence Brown come on
out alhamdulillah Allah Allah ha inama
love egg bomb mom blazing sort of cut
some kind of a lot peace be with you a
Salaam alaikum well I kasam how are you
sheikh how you've been in dr. bra hum de
la good long time I know look at that
spent a long time how's life been how's
everything been going your part of the
world yeah now things are good you know
people know you from the program that we
did originally now was actually back in
in 2007-8 i mate it was what yeah it's
got to be about six or seven years ago
we talked about you coming from the
Atheist logic right and then you grew
out of that right and actually look for
more on that coming up because I'm doing
a lot of work on how to refute atheism
right now and that's that's kind of a
focus of mine at the moment I did a
program where I actually mentioned you
and I always refer people to the
struggle that you were going through
that we all is God Almighty is telling
us that do you think you'll be left
alone on saying look I believe and you
won't be tested and how you actually you
went from having a house guest house and
losing even the guest dog or guest house
all of that and you hung in there you
were living in a day by
day motel night by motel hotel and you
talk about that in the program we did
that was your jihad your struggle it was
kind of like that old saying you know
how far the high have fallen and it's
not that I was really so high high up in
the socio-economic ladder so to speak
but but no I had things pretty good at
the time I became Muslim I was living in
a large house on him basically a state
with a guest house and and so on and had
the standard standard sort of doing a
toys of this life and then when I became
Muslim I became divorced I lost all of
that and went to a very very simple life
where because I was so financially
strapped I mean I had a quarter million
dollars just in paintings which I lost
in the divorce settlement and so I went
this very simple life where I was just
living in a studio apartment I was
renting by the week and I was sharing
that with another brother who was on
hard times and the thing that I remember
most about that time was how I was so
happy and I didn't understand why I was
saying to myself what's wrong with me I
mean I've lost my wife lost my kids my
house my car my property why my wealth
and you know different things and like I
said the paintings and the bank and why
am I happy and I realized that before
all this happened when I became when I
became Muslim and I started having
troubles with my wife and we were trying
to sort things out I kept praying is
tahara prayer which is the prayer for
guidance and in this guidance prayer you
were asking Allah to bring what he knows
to be best for you not what you think is
best but what he knows to be best for
you and you end the prayer by saying and
bless me with abundance there in and
make me pleased with it and I suddenly
realized the completeness with which
Allah answers your prayers
when when he answers your prayers down
to you know the final item that's why I
was so happy because the prayer ends
with bless me with abundance there in
and make me pleased with it and suddenly
I understood why it was that I was
feeling happy in this setting of what
you would assume to be tragedy so you
went from singing I mean it sounded like
a sad country song you know the person
they lost everything I really missed
that dog yeah and I didn't so I
mentioned I tell people to you know many
people come into Islam I think their
problems going to go away obviously you
know God is testing us and you found the
true but now once calamity struggles
come into your life you know we have to
be patient with the tests and this shows
our sincerity so I direct people to
watch this this show that we did for you
and how God Almighty replaced everything
at the end which you lost he replaced it
with that which was better yeah and this
is something I have told people a lot
over the past years I've been Muslim now
for about 20 years and one of the things
that has happened during that time so
many times people have come to me advice
asking advice about becoming Muslim and
I tell them number one expect to be
tested and number two just remember that
you don't give up anything for the
pleasure of a lot except that Allah
replace it replaces it with that which
he knows to be better for you and that's
what happened in my experience so we go
ahead and sorry what kind of leads into
our discussion about the middle path
because I've seen so many people over
the last 20 years deviate in different
directions away from the middle path and
it kind of starts from the very first
day kind of you know the person who will
accept the religion as long as it gives
them exactly what they want out of it
but if it doesn't then they go back yes
and that's a form of extremism that's
what we're going to go from there we got
to take a break and that's we want to
talk about want to talk about the
moderate the middle way
how people who come into this way of
life because the media will have
everybody program now that you accept
Islam and now you're going to end up
blowing something up blowing yourself up
doing all sorts of disaster and harming
society which the opposite should be
happening we got a lot talk with you
about here with dr. Lawrence brown on
the Dean show don't go anywhere padishah
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the DS show so dr. Brown usually
typically this is how it has happened
you know sometimes from the media they
start to feed the average layman certain
images and after so much repetition on
this people start to believe look okay a
scenario person's son daughter accept
Islam now didn't have a problem with
their son let's say being involved in in
drugs and alcoholism maybe he even went
to alternate lifestyle did all sorts of
crazy stuff and his patients were
patient with were patient with him now
he became a Muslim one who submits to
the will of God he's forgot the purpose
of life now they panic now the house is
upside down because they've been seen
from the media that some of these
converts they end up doing extreme crazy
things right okay yeah absolutely i mean
it's it's a weird thing because you see
somebody cleaning up their act going
from as you said maybe they were
alcoholic maybe they were using drugs
fornication whatever bad things you
might want to put on the list and then
they start to clean up their act and yet
when when they become muslim and that
becomes the path by which they're
cleaning up their act people people
think something is wrong and that's just
it's from the media there is no doubt
but that the media in the west is
creating a strong negative bias bias
against islam now now you also have
other parents you have people is a true
story the guy ends up seeing a muslim
praying in the street he's print cab
driver pulls up so i was praying next to
a hot dog stand
and the individual his son had accepted
Islam and then at the end he goes all
your Muslim he sees I'm praying that
says yeah he goes my son is Muslim too
and then the Muslim says are you happy
he says I can sleep at night because he
knows now what his son was involved in
and he had all these restless nights now
this person is actually a good example
of how Muslims supposed to be kinder to
his parents most to be better better
human being better to society not a
detriment to society that's that middle
moderate course is it yeah well I think
that I think that what we see time and
time again is that when people come to
really know Islam as it really is that
they lose their fears how many times how
many times have I heard people saying oh
so it's not like what I saw on
such-and-such a channel you know and
they you know when they get to know
Muslims and they learn what Islam is all
about and they see the noble manners of
the Muslims the Good Conduct the
generosity the honesty the you know
abstaining from the different sinful
vices yeah it's a completely different
picture which is why which is why it is
so important for the Muslims in the West
to remain upon the middle path because
they are they are basically the living
examples of what Islam should be to
these people who do not know okay and if
they are projecting Islam as as
something other than what it really is
then they are becoming part of the
problem rather than part of the solution
you know Islam is the religion of the
middle path and this is stressed over
and over and over again but you you find
a lot of you know overzealous converts
kind of like the reformed smoker or for
whatever reason going to the extreme of
you know fanaticism and and ending up
becoming part of the problem not part of
the solution even though this is a very
I mean the media inflates this to such a
degree that's just unbelievable but even
the statistic I did a show recently
where we actually talked about the far
greater threat to America has nothing to
do with Islam or Muslims this is a very
small minority right and we even
addressed this but I mean you have
extreme Christians radical just Robert
Robert this man was just trying to uh
nyah late a homeless some community the
president cover this at all you have so
many examples of extreme non Muslim
terrorists actually don't even get
called terrorists but obviously Islam is
free of this how have you managed to
stay obviously some people I guess they
don't get their way and they start being
neglectful of their their duties prayer
fasting all the other things that are in
comment on every Muslim or someone
become just extreme in general there's
some extreme things have you been able
to manage to stay on a middle way that
we can get some of your experiences from
when you came into now I mean I have to
say you know blessings from Allah that's
number one because it's very easy to get
pulled in one direction or another and
so that's I mean that's really that's
really what it comes down to and I think
what it has to do what a lot of it is is
following your desires if you if you're
following the religion you're following
what what comes down to us through the
Quran and through the prophetic so now
it becomes it becomes very clear that
these different extreme paths are are
off of the metal path
okay but if you start following your
desires you know for example I mean
you're a youthful hothead and you you
want to go out do something dramatic
something bigs it well there are people
out there who have deviant ideology who
you know who are looking for people like
that who they can grab ahold of in fan
the flames of fanaticism and and and
have them go out and commit a terrorist
act and then there are people in the
media who jump all over that because
they try to make the deviant individual
look normative in other words you know
that they try to make it look like
that's the normal for Islam whereas in
fact the Islamic community themselves
cast that personnel yes we're going to
go ahead and take a break we're with dr.
Laura's Brown here on the Dean show
given us some of his experiences and we
right back with more don't go anywhere
what are you going to do with it if
somebody's been trying to deliver
something to you like we've been trying
to deliver the truth that there's only
one God you worship Him alone not his
creation
welcome to the Biggio one of the most
exciting purpose of life top shells in
the world since 2006 the beam show has
been working on clearing up the many
faults misconceptions about Islam and
Muslims and at the same time delivering
the simple message of the purpose of
life in a fun and exciting way time I
was at a restaurant I was dressed like
this and the woman came to me she said
are you a rabbi so yeah I'm a black
rabbi we want you to develop a better
understanding about the pure Islam and
the real message that it teaches peace
submission surrender on obedience to
Almighty God this belief in any one of
the messengers of God is to disbelieve
in all of them schlom says love all
mankind that's why we're sharing this
message because we want the best for you
and we want the best for all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
the Dean show continued to tune in peace
be unto you please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the D show by making a
donation in the link below back here
with former major in the military Air
Force you've driven actually f-16 not
know flown alone flat floor FF 6 30 no
no I was for military I was a doctor in
the Air Force doctor and Air Force and
former atheist tried very hard to be a
Christian what was it about Islam that
just in a in a few before we get more to
the topic what was really about Islam
that captivated you well it's kind of
the subject of this talk and it's
interesting that you bring us to that
point when this is not rehearsed because
basically I was on a religious search
and I you know I'd studied the Old
Testament and that had brought me to a
study at the New Testament in my reading
of the Old Testament the Old Testament
identifies three prophets to follow and
then you come to the New Testament which
again references those three prophets
there is a scene or a passage in which
the Jews send their their scholars to
ask John the Baptist who he is and they
ask are you Elijah and he says no
and they say are you the Christ and he
says no and they say are you that
prophet and he says no and wasn't once
was not enough they then clarified they
say if you are not Elijah if you are not
the Christ if you are not that prophet
who are you and he goes on to his own
explanation but in any case the point is
that's a direct statement that the Jews
expected three prophets to follow you
know Elijah the Christ and that prophet
yes now Elijah has been aligned with
John the John that the Baptist of course
the Christ with Jesus and that left the
third ok so in studying Christianity
what I found was the same thing that I
found with Islam and that is there's a
middle path there are the extremists who
go to one of two sides the one side of
being too soft in their religion you
know and and they don't really apply the
tenets of faith as they should be
applied and then the those who swing too
far to the you know the super fanatic
side as well to to the point where you
can't even talk to them because they've
you know they've become so brainwashed
in their ideology but this choice of
going into those paths is based upon
their desires that's what they're
looking for okay on the other hand
there's this middle path where you look
for the continuity in the chain of
Revelation you look at the continuity
from you know Adam on up through the
chain of profits through Adam you know
Ibrahim or Abraham
you know Isaac is male Jacob and the
tribes Moses Jesus okay and we're left
with that one final prophet as predicted
in the New Testament and that brought me
to Islam yeah but one of the things I
noticed in all of these and all of these
scriptures is that there was a middle
path okay and in all of these scriptures
there were those who went too far into
spiritualism to where it took them
astray and there were those who went too
far into sort of a militant fanaticism
were not even militant sometimes just
fanaticism where you couldn't even talk
with these people couldn't even reason
with these people because it was their
way or the highway and and their minds
weren't even open to discussion but
between those two extremes there was the
middle path that those people who you
know were applying their religion with
reason and that led me to Islam someone
says you have all sorts of weird ideas
and someone says look as I have all
sorts of weird I know a lot of people in
general in general people have all these
weird ideas we know that look it's a
mercy that we have this guidance from
the Creator a book that's been unchanged
tamper free to ever move a living
miracle testable the Quran for anybody
sincerely who comes to a wants to know
trouve is there it tells us how we need
to live the purpose of life it's as
bright as the day as bright as the Sun
vernia wants to see who sincere now
someone says look all these religions
they're basically the same they're all
hogwash they're made up by human beings
who try to control human beings how do
we know that aliens are controlling us
there you know there this whole thing's
a fairy tale God what do you say to a
person like this look it's
understandable coming to that opinion in
one sense and that is that there are so
many deviations in religion that it is
hard to find it is hard to find that
middle path it is hard to find those who
are upon the truth but you know you
don't have counterfeit money unless
they're sump up somewhere is real money
okay you never you never counterfeit
something that doesn't exist to begin
with okay so counterfeit money exists
because real money exists do you
understand what I'm saying brilliant I
love you can't you can't fake something
that is not there to begin with mm-hmm
all right so the fact that there are a
lot of counterfeits charlatans people
who use the religion for their own
advantage misguide the masses line their
pockets etc the fact that those people
exist does not mean that there is not a
god and that there is not a religion of
truth and that's the bottom line in the
end that's the question you have to ask
yourself do you believe in a creator we
are the creation we are the creation and
the evidence of the Creator surrounds us
so if you believe in a creator you have
to believe that in His mercy he has sent
us a message to show us the path to his
pleasure by which we can incur his
pleasure and receive the reward of that
in the hereafter and so you have to be
upon the path of looking for the
religion of truth and that brings me
back to something we were talking about
earlier which is you're saying how did I
get onto the middle path don't think
you'll do it from your intellect don't
think you'll do it from your intellect
from asking the people around you and so
on and so forth no amount of research no
amount of intelligence will bring you to
the straight path if your Creator has
not written it for you if you don't have
the humility to ask your Creator to
guide you don't expect that guidance to
come it might it might not but but true
guidance comes from our Creator not from
ourselves brilliant beautiful tell us
now for the White House maybe they want
to write you down to give a nice
presentation about Islam and Muslims
maybe Harvard University maybe another
organization wants to get a hold of you
or some people just want to get in
contact with you to ask you some
questions or read some of your books
tell us how they can find you well you
can find me on my main website level
truth
dot-com if you go to level truth calm
the Muslims can find Dawa corner which
is a corner that gives you a lot of
tools for making ghoul the non-muslims
can find can go to the site map the site
map will take you to all of my different
websites among those are a website for
atheists called reality of god.com
another website for Christians called
true to Jesus calm point being that we
as Muslims we believe ourselves to be
following the religion of truth which
was brought to us by all the prophets
and so so Jesus of course is one of the
great prophets of islam but the main
website as i said is level truths calm
thank you very much thank you very much
Douglas always a pleasure having you
here in the Dean show closer to leave
here forward to having you back again
peace be with you sound like wallet and
some water sohan alot hamdulillah yes we
covered a lot of great points here the
middle path very important we don't go
to one extreme or another so we don't
get so negligent you figured out what
the purpose of life is you've come into
this way of life oh so many benefits but
now you struggle a little bit and now
you just drop out no what happens at the
end you don't get your degree you don't
pass so hang on during the tough times
and the easy times notice all the tests
and then some people go to the opposite
extreme do fanatical crazy things like
people do in all religions but don't
blame the whole religion stand a middle
way and beautiful example counterfeit
there's a lot of counterfeit religions
out there man-made religions we don't
want to follow those but it all starts
with a sincere earnest desire to want to
know the truth so who do you ask the one
who created us the one who created you
doesn't make sense that now you just
came out of nothing and then at the end
you go back to nothing you just go to
sleep and it's all over you turn to dust
what was it all about there's got to be
a purpose do you want to know the
purpose ask the one who created you to
show you what the purpose is and visit
us here every week on a detail call us
start a healthy dialogue 1 866 to Islam
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already share our show
clothes and come back every week for
another exciting episode here in a DS
Joe we'll see you next week peace be
with you please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the D show by making a
donation in the link below
you